vamos a hacer varios ejercicios de la
línea recta pero esta vez visto en la
forma a punto pendiente en esta vez
vamos a ver la forma punto pendiente y
qué es eso
bueno lo que quiero que recordemos antes
es que ya hemos visto varios videos y
varios ejemplos de la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen que si te acuerdas un
poco la forma pendiente orden al origen
a la forma pendiente intersección con el
eje de ayer es de la forma que es igual
a mx + b donde m era la pendiente y ve
la intersección con el eje de las 10 y
ojo lo que vamos a ver hoy en la forma
punto pendiente es exactamente
equivalente a esto solamente que es otra
forma de ver las cosas como es la forma
punto pendiente bueno voy a escribir
aquí la ecuación game energía 1 es igual
y ahorita vas a ver que si uno es igual
a m que multiplica x menos x 1 donde x 1
ig1 es el punto que nos dan son las
coordenadas del punto que nos dan es por
eso que se llama punto pendiente y una
de las cosas que sí quiero que
analicemos bastante
el vídeo es que estas dos formas de ver
a las líneas rectas son equivalentes
yo puedo pasar de la forma punto
pendiente a la forma pendiente ordenada
el origen y viceversa es decir puedo ir
de una u otra y de la otra a la una
vamos a hablar de la misma recta
solamente que vista de dos maneras
distintas así que vamos a ver el primer
ejercicio dice que la pendiente es igual
a menos un décimo y además pasa por el
punto 10 2 entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
nos dan un punto por el cual pasa una
recta que es el 10,2 el 10,2 y bueno
pues entonces ya tenemos un punto y ya
tenemos una pendiente pues vamos a usar
la ecuación de la recta de la forma
punto pendiente que dice jamie nos lleva
11 es el valor de ye que nos dan de este
punto es decir ye menos 2 es igual a
menos un décimo que es la pendiente que
multiplica a x menos el valor que nos
dan de x en este punto es decir 10 x
menos 10 y ya está así de fácil y de
sencillo podemos encontrar a la recta en
su forma punto pendiente de menos 2 es
igual a menos un décimo que multiplica x
menos
y es que fíjate que algo muy importante
esto sale de la misma definición de
pendiente porque qué pasa si yo divido
todo entre x menos diez pues me quedaría
diez menos dos entre x menos díaz esto
es exactamente igual a menos un décimo y
esto quiere decir que la diferencia de
entre la diferencia de x es igual a
menos un décimo que el cambio entiende
el cambio en x es igual a menos un
décimo del taddei y entre delta de x que
es la definición de pendiente o dicho de
otra manera cualquier otro punto que te
tomes de esta línea recta si tú te fijas
el cambio en y entre el cambio en x te
tiene que dar menos un décimo y es
exactamente la definición de una línea
recta cuya pendiente es menos un décimo
y además que pasa por el punto del 10,2
es decir que esta ecuación punto
pendiente sale de la definición de la
pendiente de una recta y bueno ya que
tenemos esta ecuación de la forma punto
pendiente lo que quiero que veas es que
si la manipulamos de una manera
algebraica podemos llegar a la forma
pendiente ordenar el origen porque
fíjate bien qué va a pasar si yo
distribuyó este menos un décimo
- un décimo por equis y después menos un
décimo por menos diez menos por menos me
da más diez entre 10.001 y si ahora sumó
dos de ambos lados de la ecuación me
queda que es igual a menos un décimo de
x más tres y date cuenta que aquí ya lo
tenemos la forma pendiente ordenada al
origen donde la pendiente es igual a
menos un décimo el orden al origen es
más tres y ya pasé de uno a otro así que
vamos hacer otro ejercicio encontremos
la ecuación de la línea que contiene los
puntos 10 12 y 5.25 así que lo primero
que voy a sacar es la pendiente y la
pendiente es igual a quien al cambio
entre el cambio en x por lo tanto vamos
a calcular el cambio en y me voy a tomar
a éste como punto final y me queda 12
menos 25 y 2 menos de 1 ya esto hay que
dividirlo entre 10 o jo si este es el
punto final tiene coordenadas x 2 y 2
por lo tanto hay que tener cuidado con
el orden y el 12 tiene que quedar abajo
del 10 entonces 12 menos 25 entre 10
menos 5 y cuantos esto pues 12 menos 25
es menos 3
y después 10 5 en 5 entonces mi
pendiente es menos 13 quintos la
pendiente es muy importante encontrarla
porque recuerda que nuestra nueva forma
de ver a la línea recta es la forma
punto pendiente entonces ya tengo la
pendiente y ahora voy a utilizar uno de
los puntos me queda que ye menos 25 es
igual a menos 13 quintos de x menos 510
menos uno es igual a m que multiplica a
x menos x 1 estoy usando el punto 525
pero ojo de igual manera pude haber
utilizado el otro punto porque al final
recuerda que tanto un punto como el otro
punto existen en tu línea recta y ya
está ya tenemos aquí a esta ecuación de
la recta de la forma punto pendiente así
que bueno ya tenemos un ejercicio más y
pues creo que vamos a buen tiempo para
hacer otro ejercicio dice y el siguiente
ejercicio dice la recta tiene una
pendiente de tres quintos y además
intercepta al eje y en menos tres y
bueno si te das cuenta aquí tenemos la
pendiente y la intersección con el eje
de las 10 sería muy fácil encontrar la
ecuación pendiente
de ordenar al origen porque ya nos dan
todos los datos es decir es igual a mx
más b y nos quedaría que es igual a tres
quintos de x menos 3 sin embargo yo lo
que quiero encontrar en este ejercicio
es la forma punto pendiente así que como
le vamos a hacer para encontrar la
ecuación de la recta por la forma punto
pendiente punto pendiente y bueno
tenemos la pendiente de la pendiente es
de tres quintos por lo tanto m val de
tres quintos y bueno la pregunta va a
ser como encontramos un punto de esta
línea recta sin embargo tampoco está tan
difícil porque yo sé que esta recta
intercepta el eje de las 10 en el punto
cero menos 3 nos dicen que esta recta
intersecta al eje de las 10 en menos 3
es decir que cuando x vale 0 que vale
menos 3 por lo tanto esta recta pasa por
el punto cero menos 3 y entonces ya
tengo un punto ya tengo una pendiente ya
puedo usar la ecuación de la recta de la
forma punto pendiente y que me va a
quedar en menos de 1 es igual a m x x -
x 1 por lo tanto me va a quedar
y uno pero yo uno vale menos tres
entonces menos menos tres
esto es igual a m/m vale tres quintos
que multiplica a x menos x 1 es decir 0
x 0 pero aquí tengo menos -3 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tener más 3 es
decir ye más 3 es igual a tres quintos
por x menos 0 por x menos 0 hora de
darse cuenta de algo si no existe quito
0 pues me sigue quedando x por lo tanto
esto lo puedo escribir de la siguiente
manera esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener más 3 es igual a tres quintos de
equis y ya está aquí tenemos la solución
de esta ecuación de la forma punto
pendiente aunque tal vez aquí no se vea
tan claro en el resultado final cuál es
el punto pero ya con esto redujimos un
poco la ecuación de la recta punto
pendiente ahora fíjate bien si yo restó
un -3 de ambos lados de la ecuación
llegó a la ecuación de la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen
me quedaría que este 13 pase del otro
lado de la ecuación en me queda que es
igual a tres quintos de x menos 3 así
que vamos a hacer el último ejercicio
que dice
efe de menos 7 es igual
5 efe 3 es igual a menos 4 y aquí
tenemos puntos de la forma x
fx donde x es lo que está dentro del
paréntesis es decir menos 7 y fx es el
valor que está a la derecha de esta
igualdad en este caso 5 ya tenemos un
punto de punto menos 7.5 y el otro punto
sería el 3 menos 4x vale 3 y fx vale
menos 4 y bueno ya si tenemos dos puntos
por lo tanto ya puedo encontrar la
pendiente de esta recta recuerda que la
pendiente es la diferencia de iu entre
la diferencia de x o el cambio de yale
del cambio de x v10 2 menos de 1 es
decir menos 45 entre 3 - menos 73 -
menos 7 que es el otro valor de x el
valor del punto inicial y que me queda
aquí menos cuatro menos cinco es menos 9
y 3 - menos 7 es lo mismo que 3 + 7 lo
cual es 10 por lo tanto me quedan menos
9 décimos y ya tengo una pendiente y
tengo además dos puntos por lo tanto
puede usar cualquiera de estos dos
puntos porque ambos viven en mi línea
recta para poner la ecuación de la recta
forma punto pendiente y que me va a
quedar y en menos si no voy a tomar este
punto de aquí y menos 4 que es el valor
de james esto tiene que ser igual a la
pendiente que es menos 9 décimos es
decir menos 9 décimos que multiplica a
quien a x menos x 1 es decir x menos 3 g
menos -4 es igual a menos 9 décimos de x
menos 3 recuerda que en este caso
solamente necesitamos un punto y una
pendiente y aquí podemos simplificar un
poco menos por menos me da más y me va a
quedar que ye más 4 es exactamente igual
a menos nueve décimos que multiplica a x
menos tres y ya está aquí tenemos la
solución también de este ejercicio